in life there are things that we expect
and there's other things that we don't
expect when we think about it from a
finance point of view the things that we
might expect is okay we're going to get
a regular paycheck because of our work
and we're going to have regular payments
for things like our rent or maybe our
car payment or insurance
but then there's the unexpected things
that for the most part most of us wish
don't happen I guess there could be
unexpected positive things as well but
unexpected negative things are maybe
your car breaks down and that's pretty
important because your car breaking down
isn't just a nice to have thing or nice
thing to fix you probably need your car
to get to work and make your money you
might have an unforeseen medical expense
it for you or a family member that you
have to pay and it could actually affect
how much income you or your family is
able to get if you have to take off of
work because of that medical event and
so because of that it is very good to
save for a rainy day and have that
emergency fund now most experts will
tell you that you should have an
emergency an emergency fund that's equal
to about three to six months of your
needed expenditures we've talked about
the 50 30 20 rule which is 50 on needs
30 on Watts 20 of your after-tax income
that you're bringing in for savings and
that savings first and foremost should
be for an emergency fund until you have
a nice emergency fund and then you could
think about uh other things so let's say
there's a situation where your needs are
two thousand dollars a month you know
that's your rent your car payment your
insurance your groceries the the core
groceries that you really really need if
it's two thousand dollars a month then
an expert would say Hey you need three
to six months there so that would be six
to twelve thousand dollars of an
emergency fund if for whatever reason
you lose your job your car breaks down
uh you you have to help out a family
member then you're going to have some
reserves to be able to weather that
actual storm
now above and beyond that obviously it's
even better to save and then you can
also think about that as even a bigger
emergency fund or even put it other
places but it's really important to keep
this type of money around otherwise yeah
you could find yourself in a tough
situation